roses in Los Angeles hey Rose how are
you hi there how are you better than I
deserve what's up um I have a question
regarding my former boss who I became
very good friends with and one day she
told me that um she you know the
everything she worked for whom will be
taken away because she has an IRS debt
and so being that I am debt free and I
you know have 401k and that three in
terms of credit cards and I am also dead
for in terms of the house so and we're
paying for my daughter's college with
cash and so basically you know no money
problems for me but so I loaned her ten
thousand dollars
I know and but she's been paying two
thousand four paycheck sometimes yes
2004 how many paid well for until it
gets paid I don't know how many times
has she given you two thousand dollars
I'm half of it but sometimes it gets
delayed just half of it can't be
possible four thousand four five alright
so she still owes you three more
payments for two thousand correct but
sometimes it gets the need it's not you
know her paycheck really you still work
for her she's no longer my boss but you
know we're still good friends you know
the thing is she's very spiritual she's
very there's a lot of spiritual people
that are stupid okay she's a Christian
and there's a lot of Christians that are
stupid I'm a Christian I don't I mean
thank God that God doesn't you know he
doesn't rule us out because we're done
but this woman is out of control you got
a mess on your hands
right whenever I tell her to do your
program she says God will provide so how
do I convince her
so that whenever she God provides the
worms but he doesn't toss them into the
nest the bird has to leave the nest and
go get the worms those that don't work
don't eat it's in the Bible the diligent
prosper is in the Bible God provides
because he gave you a brain and two
hands to get your act together and clean
your mess up that's what God provided
don't blame your stupidity on god that's
so aggravating in such a damaging
witness Oh bless her heart
what a mess bless your heart in southern
is oh it's me you don't want though that
this is the Dave Ramsey show